MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK.
So the course is, at its
core, very intensive learning,
so every single
text that we read
includes at least
two disciplines.
So when we talk about,
say, linguistics,
we look at linguistics from a
very historical perspective,
but also from a very
social perspective.
So basically, we look
at language in society.
We don't just focus
on English, per se.
And we do the same with
writing, with literature,
with anthropology.
There's always a larger lens
that brings in at least two
or three disciplines.
So-- and plus we also
bring in guest speakers
from various
disciplines having to do
with the international
studies, anthropology,
history, of course,
linguistics, my own field.
And also, the students
themselves, they
come from interdisciplinary
backgrounds.
So some of them are scientists,
but others do women's studies,
anthropology, biology.
So we all, I think,
in the course,
we're primed to look at the
issues of blacks in the US
from a very interdisciplinary
perspective.
From the student
perspective, if we
think of this notion
of interdisciplinary,
I think many of them come
from the science, for example,
so they're engineers--
I think we have mostly
engineers in the course,
and we have also some
scientists biology, brain
and cognitive science.
And in these fields, often,
they look at particular problems
from very--
relatively narrow perspective.
So I think that, for
many of them, indeed,
it may have been the
first course they
took that exposed them to
a broader range of fields
within one course.